You don't put your snow
on my property!
(man)
It's not my snow.
- Yes, it is!
- But this is not your snow.
This is my property!
This is the snow.
It doesn't matter!
This is my property.
You don't blow your snow
on my property!
You don't put any snow
that was where you were
on my property.
Okay, Gary.
Love thy neighbor.
I'm always on the side
of the person being filmed,
but it's hard
to take Gary seriously
when he looks like
the poor kid on a snow day.
Something tells me
this guy just enjoys
giving Gary the business.
You don't blow snow up here!
(man)
So your yard should be
completely snow free, right?
It is snow free!
'Cause you're Gary,
right?
It is snow free,
all the way back to there.
Okay, well,
this wasn't clear.
Yes, it was clear!
It was cleared
at 11:00 a.m.
Can you yell
a little bit louder
so everyone
in the neighborhood--
I don't give a [bleep]
who the hell hears it!
He's trolling you, man.
Maintain your composure,
Gary.
- Bull[bleep]!
- But if you want to be such a--
You don't blow it here
anymore!
(man)
Okay, sir.
Now clear it out.
[bleep] you.
I'm not clearing [bleep].
You [bleep] asshole.
Yeah.
You worthless pile
of [bleep].
Yeah, Gary.
Hey, you two, what say
we bury the hatchet
with a good old-fashioned
wife swap?
(man)
What, you think I'm clearing
off that garage for me?
Look at it,
dumb [bleep].
You don't put it here!
Where should I put it?
I don't know where,
but you don't do it here.
You tell me,
your highness.
Tell me where
to put it.
- Show me!
- Not here!
- Okay.
- That's where.
Okay. Bye.
Have a nice day,
Gary.
Oh, shut the [bleep] up.
You want to have
a snowball fight later?
[bleep] you, asshole.
I know what it's like
to have an annoying neighbor.
I've lived next door
to comedian Todd Glass
for over 11 years.
[upbeat music]
[musical whistling]
♪ ♪
Hey, asshole,
put your own [bleep] trash
in your own [bleep] cans.
My trash?
It's the world's trash, Todd.
We all share
one human footprint.
Besides, you never fill up
your can, anyway.
What's the big difference?
It makes it heavier,
stupid.
It's on wheels.
We both know you need
the exercise, Todd.
Too bad you can't throw away
that dumb sleeve tattoo.
[bleep] you.
Why don't you go
do what you do best,
tell rape jokes and alienate
half the world's population?
And stop putting
your porno in my trash.
It's recycling.
Your garbage should be
honored, Todd.
I'm famous famous.
You're only mildly
recognizable.
Nobody's going through
your trash for porno.
I don't even like that
type of porno, moron!
What are you gonna do
on your show this week?
Oh, let me guess.
Get naked and talk about
how dumb women are?
Sounds like a good episode.
What are you gonna do?
Record another podcast?
I used to do the same
thing as a child--
sit in my closet
and pretend to talk
to imaginary listeners.
Your trash reeks
of [bleep].
Is Brickleberry in there?
[bleep] off, Todd.
The only reason it smells
is because I eat
a lot of seafood--
expensive seafood.
Okay, that was
clearly a bit.
Todd cannot afford to live
in my neighborhood.